servus und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge der hacker schon heute
wieder mit dem mord hinken was geht der
aber nicht fit ist
man ist ein bisschen angeschlagen auf
jeden fall habe ich max gezwungen heute
dabei zu sein egal ob krank ist nicht
wollte was natürlich bietet dann
geschaut ja platz 5 heißt lobby hacker
angeles ke von flix müssen aber einen
job meint vornherein ist man in der
lobby hätten ja das habe ich ja schon
der all den leuten so ein bisschen
beigebracht dass lobby hätten so das
allerletzte ist es einfach so im leben
bestimmt noch eine abgehobene hätte ist
noch zwei die decken
warum siehst du die antworten auf das
offene meer genommen hat ist doch 3 ich
hab mir sind drei arten ändern
aber er ist auf jeden fall vom hektar
was wirklich zählt übrigens schon alles
klar 10 von 10 punkten auf der hobby
losigkeit skala für diese menschen hier
er hat in seinem leben abgeschlossen
ganz ehrlich wer ist einfach fertig
plaz fir eis hacker aufnahmen auf dem hd
punkt net von kuki deluxe 33 den namen
kommen erst ab 69
als es vor eingespeichert for android
eingetippt gut zu wissen das war
übrigens die effektivste strategie sie
einfach rauszufliegen dahin zu verstehen
was macht der denn da hat jemand tnt um
das fliegen zu können weil das braucht
of poker ich glaube man kann nicht
einfach so den kontakt zum boden
verliere man braucht irgendein explosion
oder so achtet drauf und bock nämlich
zack war ja wieder anheben das hat das
ist es dass der träger die irgendwie
immer für das tnt boost ach so weiter er
jetzt maschine titel schreiben jetzt
weiter also die aufnahme läuft noch ein
verfolgt ihn noch weiter gibt es nämlich
hexe für das team eine automatische
krippe autorama gibt's ja da unten ist
wieder unser unser guter hacker zack
zack zack zack zack gesammelt die auf
und ihr uns angezogen hat auto aber
danach aber noch irgendwo im rumpf liegt
also leute braucht mal wieder ein tnt
oder um loszufliegen hat er ein
doch hier ist ein zauberer oh gott wir
hängen geblieben kann man seine 1990 der
typ mit 17 dieses jahr
tnt tnt wieder am start jetzt noch rein
ins wasser runter sich hertreibt alter
den mediaetat vorgeschlagen der doch
buchstäblich alles drin was ja nur slow
down alles möglich
ganz schön ganz schön viele hacks leute
für den platz vier
deswegen hoffe ich dass platz drei da
mithalten kann ahmann beiden schlafen
besitzt kann ich noch nicht wissen dass
einstellt wenn ich mich drauf setzte
platz 3 heißt hacker auf die facebook
net klammer auf tnt und stammt von dem
jungen heisst boxer wurde boxer ist sein
name der schule mit der gans wenn 134
sind auch schon nach das ist eventuell
nicht mit rechten dingen zugehen könnt
ihr alle bauern verschoss das sieht
denkt man gerade wie seltsam mäßig
bewegt alter kämen
jeder hat mir so was eben so war sofort
klar dass ich einfach alles was er macht
ist seltsam aus ist wenn das war bisher
sehr komisch aus wenn ihn stellt ich
meine klar hätten das nicht sieht oder
aber man muss halt auch nicht sexuell
belästigen sich irgendwie von vorn
herein drängen
was macht der hhl hat report glaube ich
ein chat kann das seiner moderator dann
denk ich mal was mit ihm passiert für
das schaffen würde dem moderator
überstehen oder wieder drauf gehen und
vernichtet werden wenn heute was deshalb
ist hoch für zwei alta mining leidet ja
doch der gaildorfer aber der backe gegen
wie beschissen worden daher jetzt deine
luft alles klar unter die leute
zwar nehmen sie würden es gibt es eigene
kampagne so eine politische kampagne
also können wir irgendwann diesen
hashtag erklären hashtag john f ich habe
meine aggressions probleme sind zurück
aber platz drei ist auch da war mir gib
mir gefällt der titel schon mal extrem
gut dummer hacker heck vor augen eines
mords magic in the sky beziehungsweise
er hat beides wir drei geschrieben ist
jemand der schon die hacker schon sehr
lange schaut und jeden insider kennt
unser name ist er hat es allerdings auf
einer kartoffel aufgenommen das stimmt
wenn ich mir das richtig anschaue ist
das eine mittel festkochende kartoffel
aus dem jahr 2013
hier ist man spaß hat es aufgenommen ja
auf einem mittel fest kommt aus dem jahr
2013 denkst du an witz okay leute
schauen wir doch mal an
scheinbar ist hier morgen da runter und
ich ahne schon welcher modus ist gut ich
habe hier schon gesehen haben mag es
nicht natürlich der gute bak sind wir
erinnern uns akasaka senf ist irgendwie
so das ist ein fall für galileo mystery
nakas entführt immer in den runden wo
leute gerade hecken er war auch in der
runde wo die leute sich nimmt diamant
rüstung effekt haben und op rechte und
20.000 herzen in zweifel games ist hier
seht ihr das video nicht gesehen habt da
und hab ich das video verlinkt falls es
noch nicht gesehen habt sehr seltsam
oder selbst schon wieder eine einsendung
stellt was passiert wenn man ein haar
vor seiner macht hacker senf leute
passen wirklich gepasst ganz ehrlich nur
ein harter vollen das ak senf wird
hacker senf deswegen ist meine roten
ball so mit den hacker unter einer decke
steckt irgendwann mal sagen also der typ
steht da er steht richtig nahe
und ich glaube diese weise typ mit
diesem komischen fach optische hacker ja
und acker selbst steht dabei warum wand
der ihn nicht gefeiert
vielleicht oder es ist ein zweiter kran
wieder hin und her bankrotter vater
blinken like a motherfucker aber was
macht der ackerbau kannst du mal kicken
aka aka komba weiter des amtes gegen kik
in kenia bis die leute wissen es
aca saint phalle einfach zu sagen ok hab
mein kumpel heckt hier mit dem hinter
einer decke steckt übrigens aber wo man
irgendeiner schaut doch geradezu kann
zeigt kann es sein dass es klüger die
aufnahme der hacker chance sehen so war
es dann okay ich tue mir auf seriösem
banden
aber leute acker sind hacker senf müssen
wir noch mehr wissen
so leute platz eins habe ich grade
gehalt das jetzt platz zwei kommt ich
hoffe nicht als ein stand auf jeden fall
von lampions films schauen wir rein was
spielte über oder kontakte oder kassiert
noch mit einer lufthansa maschine ist
klar der titel eyes hacker herzen
das heißt wir müssen auch auf die herzen
achten nicht gesehen aber ansonsten
scheint endlich zu spielen als sieger
sieht ansonsten gar nicht so schlecht
rosberg rückte jetzt gleich acht mal
acht und auf den chat also er kassiert
schon deutlich mehr hitze zahl zehn
volle herzen den getötet hat weil die
ganzen eingeschlagen und hätten auch
töten
finde ich bei den deutlichen mails geben
immerhin meist auf timo die täter
20.10.10 herzen sind 10
da steht aber 10,0 sonst hätte ich keine
kommastelle herstellt also zuerst zehn
volle herzen das passt einfach nicht
er kriegt er kriegt hier ein volkssport
hab jetzt fällt nicht gesehen aber wir
haben gerade 23 so dann läuft er hier
durch die lava und kassiert dann noch
deutlich mehr wert xxx feuer das kann
ich seine muss vorher dauern kann das
kann nicht sein
heldt ist es aber auch etwas das mit
film kranke heck die da vor allen dingen
das ist eigentlich richtig richtig
schlau sage ich mal so zu hacken weil
eigentlich mann scheint die recht ist
scheint alles zu sein kriegst du kriegst
nordberg frist schaden alles aber du
verlierst du keine herzen
leute wie kann es seinen platz eins ist
wie immer mysterium wie kann das sein
ist es eine anzeige back theoretisch
denkbar aber er hätte vorher sterben
müssen eigentlich mag nicht gesehen dass
er gegen ein getrunken hat in der zeit
der andere hatte auch fast voller herzen
als sie dann entfalten gange sind er hat
zu dem zeitpunkt 9 herzen wohl den
ersten hit von dem anderen bekommen oder
anderen vorher schon drei fouls
gefressen hat halt kein heizmann
gefunden gras das ist komisch also der
müsste eigentlich tot sein
aber ist nicht gestorben und zehn herzen
werden angezeigt
saukomisch also er ist quasi unbesiegbar
war es eine anzeige ich glaub nicht ob
wie kann es denn sonst gäbe es keine
anzeige back ist wie geht das
und wieso ist acker sind bei den
illuminaten müssen die kommentare und
addiert eure monitore